Wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
before we did anything because this is
my third event in a row through
turning-point and today partly with the
Iran Institute I was at UMass on Monday
and it was a great event totally
respectful and fun challenging questions
with you guys really just a great
exchange of ideas everything that I'm
that I'm living for at the moment and
then I was at the University of New
Hampshire yesterday live here tonight
yeah well it is closer to died yesterday
is just an absolute circus there they
could not secure a room on campus
because of threats they moved us about
300 students they moved us to a 7,500
seat hockey arena which was I thought
that was in an episode of veep right
just like a faith background or
something and just and screaming and
noisemakers and all of the things that
you guys have come to know these are the
things that are shutting down civil
discourse so I hope tonight that will it
will do it severally we are completely
open you know Your Honor I just
discussed we will we will take any and
all questions that you guys have we have
no plan right now other than to talk it
out and we agree on some stuff some
stuff we disagree on you notice she's to
my right and I in some ways I Bobby's
become somebody that is to the right of
your on Bill which now I'm sure
Huffington Post will call me all right
did you guys see this today at Vanity
Fair another one of these hit pieces I
mean these people are not everyone that
I'm friends with apparently is a Nazi
which you know as a former member of the
IDF so the point is if there are any
protesters here he knows how to use a
gun so be careful so we're gonna talk
about free markets we're gonna talk
about free speech we're going to talk
about all the things that I think you
guys know that we we care about and and
we're excited to be here so I thought
first off I'm gonna throw something kind
of interesting at you I think something
seriously big shifted in the universe
last week because of Kanye West you know
I'm more the Frank Sinatra guy myself
but but Kanye I think by tweeting seven
words I love the way Candace Owens
thinks he offered oxygen to the space
that I think you guys are in and that
were in he just offered a little space
for some other people to think a little
bit differently to look a little more
critically at some of the issues that
we're constantly talking about and and
he's talking about the individual and I
with a second that happened I called you
and I said this is a moment for you guys
because Kanye West is talking about the
individual do you think I'm crazy for
this thought no I think I think we are
at an interesting moment in time I think
that I actually think they laughed and I
know I know a lot of people disagree
with madness I think the left is in
retreat the left is completely and
utterly bankrupt and I think New
Hampshire was kind of evidence of that
when you're completely bankrupt when you
have nothing to say when you have
nowhere to go
you get noisemakers and you make lots of
noise because you can't actually
communicate anymore you all you can do
is yell and shout and scream and you
know you you're like a little child
because you'll completely all you have
is emotion you have no mind anymore and
I really think that the left is
it's not dead obviously because it holds
the universities in a whole mass of
political power still
but the radical the crazy the nutty left
is an illustration of that this whole
thing is in decline and even Kanye West
sees it right so it's gotten to the
point we even some people in pop culture
are looking at these people and saying
no no this this is nuts
the there's not there's no there there
there's nothing there's nothing to hold
on - there's no values there well what
do we do with these people and I think
of all the communities the black
community should be the one at the
forefront of this because they've been
betrayed by the left for generations now
you know since the civil rights movement
where yes the people stood up for them
and and marched with them and and they
deserve all the credit in the world for
doing that but since that the war
poverty has not helped them all the all
the whole welfare state everything that
the government is tried to do to
so-called help them has actually made
them worse off and things are worse I
mean Chicago is probably the best place
in the world right now to see this right
because they are worse off than if
they'd never be in a war on poverty if
they'd never been you know certain parts
of the Civil Rights Act if they've never
been this massive attempt somehow to
help them you know say mother government
is here to help you right that is a
awful awful sign when somebody says that
right to you so I think I think I think
the bankrupt I think they're out of
ideas I don't know if you saw Bernie
Sanders the latest idea is that the
governor's guarantee a job to everybody
everybody gets a job like like if you
can't find a job in the private sector
we'll pay you 15 bucks an hour you can
dig ditches and fill them in right all
day long they can fill they can fill and
and this is a serious proposal we've got
two other Democrats who are running for
president who have endorsed this Booker
and not Camilla Harris the the the
from New York the New York senator yeah
go ban right
I mean this is naughty did you just
announce that they're both running for
president I did and you know that's just
so stupid great that that there's
nothing there's nothing there the real
question is and they were question is
okay so what what now right what what
were places that what fills the void
what what is what is the alternative to
this nuttiness and the idea to Kanye
West is talking about the individual I
don't know what he means by that I see
all kinds of tweets by him some of them
make sense of them completely weird yeah
but if we can start having a discussion
about the individual and what that means
and and there may be what individual
rights mean and and what is
individualism mean and maybe get him a
copy The Fountainhead maybe can read
that then it becomes interesting then
we're talking about the right kind of
things if the alternative is sorry make
America great again
then I'm dubious you know may come I can
eat again there's a big guy I don't know
that that's the answer that I like this
idea of talking about the individual
well look I I don't know that it's the
answer either I don't think look as I
said in my direct message last week I
don't know what Kanye's political
beliefs are at any moment you know all
of these people that are now worshipping
him as a hero they most likely will come
to regret it when he does something
nutty but I think he offered oxygen to a
space that needed a little oxygen you
know a few of us what what Eric
Weinstein calls the intellectual dark
web there's been this group of about
twenty people kind of trying to just say
you know what some of us are on the Left
sam harris some of us are on the right
ben shapiro but we're trying to figure
out what the answers are without
destroying each other and i think Kanye
offered a little air to that but also
what's interesting to me is the way the
media suddenly just went on a complete
rampage against him
and the lead moment in in Twitter
moments was about far right Candace
Owens far right Candace Owens who's had
dinner at my house with me and my
husband I mean this woman she's not a
gracious black by the way not that black
people can't be racist but they're
calling her anti black the way that
they're you know all these hit pieces
run on Kanye did you guys see the the
piece that Maxine Waters released a
statement about Kanye that he should
basically stay in his lame and and and
it's like this is actually the soft
bigotry of low expectations that that
someone dares to think differently and
you say no no we're gonna put me back
plantation where we've kept you yeah
exactly and this has to be thought no it
definitely and and I think it also gives
a you know space now to other people in
the entertainment business that you know
as you know yeah a silent because
they're afraid and he gives space to I
think that minority community that feels
betrayed by the left to speak out
against it and and that they've never
spoken they're not afraid to speak to
that point I almost every day now I get
a direct message on Twitter from
somebody that's a public person either a
musician or an actor or something
telling me that they agree with me but
they won't say it publicly I got
something today from somebody in the
music biz that most of you probably know
saying that they they're afraid to come
out of the closet what do you mean I
mean that was the phrase they used I
mean were you part of friends of Abe the
secret society in Hollywood do we always
talk about that it was before I before I
moved to LA you have to be a secret
society in Los Angeles called Friends of
Abe which was all the directors produces
lighting people everybody in the film
industry who was left of I don't know
Lennon a right of lenders Yeah right you
know right of right of of a leftist
agenda and they used to get together and
there was a coffee shop in Hollywood
where like every Wednesday they would
get you know people would get together
and wasn't that many of them and then
once in a while they have these big
gatherings and I went once in a while
3,000 people and a lot of people like I
know that guy I know you know all these
movie stars they you don't know and they
all stay silent because they were afraid
we're talking about 3,000 people some of
them the biggest some of the biggest
producers in Hollywood some of the
biggest
actors in Hollywood will not come out as
being conservatives of being a
libertarian or being anything other than
the left because they're afraid for
their livelihood but that's why I love
doing these events with you guys because
I truly believe this that we are living
in such a unique time right now where
everything is up in the air the world
truly is yours when you get out of
college like ever there is nobody that
knows what's gonna happen tomorrow much
less than a year from now nobody knows
the Trump has just tossed the chessboard
up the pieces or everywhere and you guys
will be able to make the future and the
funny thing is when I agreed to do some
events with Iran and AR I I got people
telling me that oh you know I'm working
with these these far-right maniacs and
I've got to know you pretty well and
you're constantly screaming about
freedom I mean all you care about the
only thing you care about is freedom and
so it leads me to this I want to do a
little poem let's do it by applause so
that the live stream people can catch it
how many of you at one time were on the
left yeah I could be in that area yeah
and and how many of you would say you're
conservative now how many conservative
yeah it supposed to clap yeah still
doing the hands okay how many of you are
libertarian there's always there's
always one loudly there's a few Chuck
Barry Johnson ladies and gentlemen right
here yeah how many of you are
Objectivist
[Applause]
how many of you are progressives do we
have any progressives here with a little
rule and you you kind of oh we got one
right here and you kind of nodded half a
little bit you're I don't know if you
were just shifting in your seat but
that's great I mean I would love for
progressives to be here and I'd love to
take a question from you maybe at the
end so all right so we have a little
oxygen in this space I do believe
perhaps something has happened where
we're starting to win a little bit I
think that there's their lashing out the
way they are because if they're sort of
like a wounded animal at the end who
you're trying to put your hand out there
and offer them something and they only
know how to strike back so just very
quickly last night when I was at
University of New Hampshire there was a
what you know there's they're screaming
and they're shouting me down and they
got their noisemakers and their
repetitive droning I mean the the chants
they're like robots or zombies or
whatever but there was a woman in the
back who I had been talking about Jordan
Peterson and we'll put him on the map
obviously was the bill in Canada the
trans bill that if you misgendered
somebody you could potentially face a
fine which perhaps could have become a
law and then imprisonment and all sorts
of things and Jordan said I have no
issue with trans people but I don't want
the government to be allowed to tell me
what I can and cannot say I think most
rational people can agree with this and
I told that story and there was a trans
woman in the back and she started
yelling at me and you know telling me I
don't like trans people and all that and
I told her that I want her to have the
same rights as everyone else and live
with the same dignity as everybody else
and and hopefully find someone that
loves her in life and can find goodness
and all that stuff and I said is there
anything that I just said there that
would lead you to believe that I'm
transphobic or a bigot or anything and I
could see it in her she didn't know what
to do so she basically just yelled that
she hated me or something to that effect
and we have the video of this and maybe
we'll release it I don't want to make it
about her because I think you know the
other guys often are attacking people I
don't want to attack people I want to
attack ideas but I but I thought it was
a good example of where we're at at the
moment which is there ain't much left
but now my question for you is how do
you show people that they can get out
and that they can realize that freedom
and limited government and free markets
and all of that
truly is the answer well first before
you say that I just want to support what
you said because I think it's really I
mean there really is a backlash against
these people and and you can see it
I think Berkeley is a great example of
this right last year Ben Shapiro tried
to speak at Berkeley and and tifo went
nuts and everybody went nuts and it was
shut down and the University did nothing
this year the university said no we
believe in free speech we're actually
gonna let everybody speak I mean you'd
think they got that earlier but you know
maybe it took a few riots and this year
but real spoke and yeah the university
has spent six hundred thousand dollars
to protect Tim six hundred thousand
dollars so a little Orthodox Jew could
give it up each do you realize how
insane that is but in an odd way you
went to Berkeley and I went to Penn it
was you know and I don't think they
spent six hundred thousand but they it
was a lot of security well it was wrong
it was fine but it happened and the
point is that I think even
administration's that some of these
universities are figuring out that maybe
the wrong strategy is to just let this
run amok and and that's a good sign how
do you do it how do you convince people
and this is the key because the key is
to have an alternative to have an
alternative to what the left is offering
and there has to be something positive
that you have to inspire people with and
I think that positive has to be at a
personal level I think I think politics
takes care of itself I don't think that
debate at the end of the day and a
challenge at the end of the day and the
discussion at the end of the day needs
to be at the political level the real
question is do you as an individual want
to be able to make decisions for you do
you value your life do you value your
life enough to be to one to live your
life to the fullest and be able to make
decisions about who you sleep with and
who you marry and about what kind of
business you want to start and what kind
of profession you enter without getting
permission right so once you leave
college do you get to make decisions for
yourself is your life valuable enough to
be able to you to be able to make those
decisions for yourself that is really
the key question and if the answer is
yes I want to make decisions for myself
then everything else follows easy
from that and yes I have the tool to
make those decisions my mind we all have
this reasoning capacity we all have the
tool to make decisions and to live well
for ourselves then everything else flows
from that then it means that but out
right but out of my life leave me alone
which is all basically what we're asking
politically is let the government be
there to protect us from people wanting
to intervene in our lives with force and
other than that leave us alone
because we can take care of ourselves so
I'm gonna make your own blush here for a
second I've told the story once or twice
I think I said it to you to your face
what last time you did my show but he's
not just saying this this isn't just
stuff he's saying he's really telling
you something on the human level that is
very true and I know it because I heard
it from him and it changed my life so as
some of you may know we were on Ora TV
the Reuben report was on or a TV for a
while after we left the Young Turks and
the show that's when the show really
started blowing up and bigger the show
got the more that the network wanted
from us and and some of their failing
shows they were kind of letting skate by
and I couldn't really understand that I
thought you need to be giving us more
now so that we can expand but instead
they wanted to take more from us and I
had never met you before before you had
been on my show you came in we sat there
for an hour and your own talked about
rational self-interest and why you
should fight for the things that you
believe in and that you shouldn't just
give of yourself endlessly and
everything else that you just said and
we finished that interview I walked
right into the control room and my team
was in there and I said to them guys I'm
gonna leave here and I hope you'll come
with me and fortunately the guys that I
wanted to come with me came with me and
from that moment of two months later we
launched independently and my life
completely changed and the show has
blown up since then and I've used those
ideas I mean the way that I've even
built my business has been with these
principles so I know that these are real
things these aren't he's not just
sitting here saying take charge of your
life as if as if it's some like you know
mumbo jumbo it's something that's real I
know and I'm saying it because it
affected to me this is like a thousand
times more important to politics
I mean what's really important what you
an individual do with your life whether
you take responsibility for it whether
you really understand that you got one
shot at this
there's no we play every second you live
you don't get again right never waste a
second in that sense it's about living
life to the fullest and making the most
of that life and not just you know it's
hard for when we're this big that we
should sacrifice fathers or we should
compromise and we shall always do what
the majority wants no none of that is
true
all of that is bad advice right break
the rules I was just with somebody today
and he said he's giving a commencement
address to the high school at ways Dada
goes and he's and he's the theme is go
break the rules and he asked me which
rules would you break you know that's
hard I need to think of it as a positive
I said I said you know two rules two
principles that are the positives like
live for yourself think for yourself and
then what rules does that break well
break them all code that has taught you
you shouldn't live for yourself that
your purpose in life is to live to
others that the purpose in life is the
sacrifice that the noblest thing you can
do in life is to sacrifice for others
right no live for yourself you want to
help others help others but do it
because it's good for you because it's
good for the world in which you live in
right how do you how do you think the
branding here got so MUC DUP because I
think most people intuitively know this
I see a lot of you guys nodding and
obviously you know who we are so we have
a somewhat selected crowd here but when
we talk about this stuff now and again I
mean bringing it back to Kanye all he
did was say to people think and that
that has become controversial something
happened with the branding and maybe it
is all the things that we talked about
about academia and that the schools and
I'm sure you guys are suffering from
some of this here professors that are
indoctrinating you instead of teaching
you and if you dare say anything that's
you know anything remotely close to
small government you'll you'll you know
get guff for it last night I had a
student or a UMass I had a student who
was telling me about all those anti
and Anton conservative stuff that their
professor was telling them about I said
what class is this biology but this is
but this is actually real so what do you
think happened that allowed this to get
so confuse well I mean that assumes that
it's some event that happened on
different issues it's different things
that have happened so on the issue of
living for yourself
I mean this is a battle we'd be fighting
for 2,000 years really since the Greeks
rate Christianity is anti this idea that
you should live for yourself it's all
about sacrifice right but the
Enlightenment got it right the founding
fathers of this country the Declaration
of Independence does not say you have a
right to sacrifice you should work for
your community give charity and do
community service that's not in the
Declaration of Independence the
Declaration of Independence says you
have a right to your life you have a
right to your Liberty and you have a
right in the most self-interested
political statement in all of human
history you have any in the a leopa
right to pursue your happiness not some
group happiness right all right the
libertarian hit so the Enlightenment got
it right and but since 1900 and I know
this is more history of philosophy maybe
didn't want to hear but since 1900 the
or 1800 there's been an effort primarily
by the Germans by the way primarily an
effort to undercut this - to subvert it
in the name of tribalism in the name of
collectivism in the name of religion in
the name of fill-in-the-blank but to
undercut the achievement of the
Enlightenment and the to another line
there's two ideas reason as efficacious
as the tool by which we survive and
thrive and individualism the idea that
the individual is what matters
those two ideas have been undercut
systematically from Kant from Hegel
Schopenhauer Marx all the way to
Nietzsche and then of course the moderns
have just taken that up and as the left
has become more
more dominant in the universities as it
has to the last hundred years I mean it
was bad when I went to school 30 40
years ago it's a hundred times worse now
right it's just getting worse and worse
as they become more dominant those ideas
have become the dominant ideas that
everybody talks about and now you're
supposed to be regimented in your whim
worship you all supposed to have the
same emotions you know you are not
allowed to think thinking is is is it's
this thing that white males do and it's
you know it's impressive reason is
oppressive yeah reason is depressing it
so it really has become dominant within
the culture in which we live dominant in
the world which we do in academia and
this is why I think most Americans feel
alienated from academia cuz they go what
do you mean if cuz I should live for
myself at least to some degree right of
course I you know I should I should
think what's this about not thinking
this is stupid right and you just see
this alienation between a lot of
Americans who didn't go to college and
who maybe in the middle of the country
or didn't go to the big really left-wing
schools and the people who go to school
the people who get brainwashed by the
professor and not brainwashed but but
all they hear is one message so I think
it's turned slowly over over over a long
period of time and it's a it's a it's a
turn that's happy it's deep right it's
it's deep fuller it's philosophically
deep it's not just something in politics
to change yeah it's something about a
view of the fundamental nature of
reality and of mankind so I want to dive
into that a little bit because we
haven't done too much of that together
but quickly I'm curious how many of you
actually agree with what I started with
that something maybe has shifted and
perhaps we're winning now let's do it by
applause again
so I I really do believe that and and
that's gonna be the interesting place
but let's let's get to some of that
underpinning of this because you know I
talk with with so many people who I who
I admire who are great thinkers from Sam
Harris and Jordan Peterson and Michael
Shermer and Steven Pinker who you
mentioned in a series of those people
and there seems to be a debate sort of
whether whether reason alone is enough
of the bedrock to form free societies or
whether that has to come from as you
know Shapiro calls it an unmoved mover
or from some other belief in something
that basically I had a conversation with
Michael Shermer and Dennis Prager on my
show about this about God and morality
and Dennis's position Dennis of course
is a believer Dennis's position is that
on a micro level any of us can be good
without God that we can we can choose
good things and be moral etc but that on
a macro level a society can't without
God now obviously my Michael Shermer
takes the opposite position which is
where you are but can you talk about
that a little bit sure and and let me
just say before I talk about even that
that Michael Shermer and I are gonna
disagree about what morality is we're
gonna agree that you can have morality
without God but we're gonna disagree
about what morality is and even this
issue of a reason
Sam house and I might disagree on what
reason is right and what it really means
so there's a lot of juicy interesting
philosophical discussions to be had yeah
I mean uhm we're in theory you you guys
disagree on free will which is you can't
have reason without fool in my view so
he's talking about reason what does he
even mean if you if you're not even
making choices if it's not you making
choices if he's just an automaton so if
you disagree freewill you disagree
really about everything but that's
that's to me where the juice is where
the real interesting discussion is and I
think what the left the the knotty left
is done is this excluded itself from
even this debate because it won't even
engaged right they just yell and scream
and shout but the interesting debate is
happening it can happen should happen
between Jordan Peterson between sam
Harris myself the Weinsteins these are
the people who should be having this
debate because this real philosophical
issues to be worked out right to be
under
to be discovered to be to be figured out
it's not simple it's not straightforward
now the idea that morality morality is a
code by which to live your life by which
to make important decisions in your life
right to know what is good and what is
bad what is the right path and what is
the wrong line the ideas that is
dependent on something written in some
ancient book or is dependent on some
person's ability to commune with spirits
right which is basically what religion
demands either you believe in some book
or you commune with spirits and get
information directly or you have an
intermediary who communes with the
spirits and get but even when I say it
it sounds so ridiculous it's it's hard
to take seriously but you know so so if
I don't believe in the spirits and I
don't believe in this ancient book I
can't make proper decisions about my own
life now take Dennis Plagueis argument
that yeah you can you can but as a
society we can't what does that mean
that means that most of you can't it
means the most of you are too stupid to
take care of yourself most of you be too
stupid to understand what right and
wrong is what's good for your life
what's bad for your life what will lead
to horrible consequences what will lead
to good consequences and therefore we
use we had to sell you a story about
fairies and gremlins and and and stuff
in order for you to be Malo in order for
you and now that to me is absurd
morality is about figuring out and this
is where funnily enough sam harris and i
at least on the approach agree morality
is about looking out at the world and
empirically figuring out what is good
for human beings and what is bad what
leads the flourishing and success and
what leads the destruction death disease
and starvation wait
that's what mora and then do the things
that lead to success and avoid the
things that lead to death and
destruction not that hard right now it's
a little bit more complicated than and a
little harder than that but basically
that's the that's the chore that your
ethics department if you have a
philosophy department yo your ethicist
should be thinking about what
are they actions the values that people
should pursue that lead to success in
life that lead to flourishing to
happiness to just a sense of well-being
about the world and what are the actions
and since we're all of the same species
but most the time I think that yeah most
of the time you know if you eat if all
of us eat sign it would pretty much all
die right
this shouldn't we got a great ending of
this show by the way just stay tuned for
that
yeah and they claim guru and cultists
yeah
I'm really trying to max out the YouTube
views you know we have our particular
nature so just like wait about
particularly nature in the material
sense it's a thing if you take a knife
you know I'm just waiting for Dave yeah
well yeah some things have certain
impacts the same thing in the spiritual
realm if I lie all the time it has a
sudden impact on my life not a good one
so it's pretty easy if you're a kid and
experiment a little bit lying and test
it out a little bit to figure out lying
not a good strategy in life if you want
to make friends and make money and be
successful only profession in the whole
universe when lying actually leads to
success is yeah and that's why who cares
about politics that's a boring stupid
subject it's right that everybody and I
always say if you ever met have you ever
met a happy flourishing really a
politician who you go wow what a life
this person lives this oh my god no the
whole Bush clan looks like miserable
pathetic human beings I mean that last
the last guy who gave you that sense of
probably George Washington right and I
mean I can't think of it look at look at
the Clintons I mean they look like they
want to do it and slit their own wrists
I mean so the idea is let's go out there
this is what morality should do let's go
up and figure out what leads to human
success what deletes the individual
human success and do that and that's
what morality is moral he's not some
Mystikal crazy strange science that we
have to commune with the spiritual at
the figure right now it's an empirical
sign it's just like any other science
what succeeds what fails let's do the
stuff that succeeds and don't do the
stuff that fails that's it so no you you
you and and succeed means live well and
live well means long-term cuz you know
Ben's gonna come in and say what about
the chick at the bar you really want the
Chicot the bar right yeah I mean he did
that on your show like no I don't really
want the Chicot the bar because I know
the consequences of the chick at the bar
so it never never really enters my mind
right because I love my wife and I want
to stay with her and this is stupid
right so there is no short-term
self-interest short-term is a win
worshiping going by your motion is anti
self-interest it's anti mall it's a Malo
so don't do it
no so no I the flip side is that what is
religious morality its whatever somebody
you know made up its unconnected to
reality its non-scientific
it's made up stuff and it's completely
subjective and it means actually nothing
it's it's the least objective morality
possible because it's it's you know this
is why how many sects of Protestantism
are they like I don't know 100 200 right
because they don't feel like following
that commandment and they go and do it
out something else right they start they
won't sick were you allowed to do that
thing right if you put 50 rabbis in a
room to study a particular paragraph
how many opinions are gonna have on that
paragraph 51 at least yeah so you know
what was the objective nature of
morality coming out of of this
experience no the only objective
morality is in a morality that is
derived from real reality from from the
world out there scientifically right
it's science so what I love about this
conversation is that all of the people
that you just mentioned that we've been
talking about that I know you guys
follow and listen to podcasts and things
these people are actually friends and
and
and truly comrades I know a bad word for
a group of freedom lovers here comrades
in the best sense of comrade but but the
fact that these people whether it's
Denis or Michael or whoever that at the
end of the day whatever those
differences are we're actually relishing
those differences at the moment I mean
we really are and I think that that's
what's driving people to us but this
endless hysteria has now driven people I
would have never made sense to me well
but five years ago before I really was
doing this version of what I'm doing
that all I would be talking about every
day is that you should live life free
and once once that hit me once I really
had that revelation well then it did
change a lot of my politics and I know
you think the politics part are the
boring part of this but it led me to now
being for free markets and some of those
other libertarian and classical liberal
because I think that's right but I think
this is the kind of debate that needs to
happen right the kind of philosophically
deep debate about these issues that
matter and you can have this debate and
still be respectful and total respect
out of sight this is not easy stuff it's
not obvious right and and it's it's
interesting and engaging to have the
debate and the discussion and I think
that's what you're facilitating what
you're facilitating is really the
creation why this movement is kind of
building around Dave right is because
Dave is facilitating a conversation and
would would what I invent your peer will
have a conversation independent of David
I don't think so right I mean there's a
certain or Bret Weinstein because we
come from things so definitely but the
conversation I don't think we're gonna
convince each other I never go into a
debate think can we convince the other
guy never know even if but you guys are
gonna benefit immensely from it and and
thousands of other people are gonna
benefit immensely from hearing to
intelligent people who disagree talk
about a topic that's important in a
respectful you know rational way the
world benefits from it even if we don't
we're not again with most of us a tool
to really change these these ideas and
we're too fixed in our ways but the
conversation is fascinating and benefits
all of the people who listen to it yeah
that's what I love that's why I love
coming to colleges I mean the fact that
you guys care about this stuff is
amazing to me I mean I'm not that much
older than you I'm a little old I was in
college in 94 to 98 I'm 41 I spent four
years Logan Power on there hey what you
guys what year would most of you guys
born go [ __ ] yourselves this is so great
this is why I stopped being a professor
you see the thing that sucks most about
being a professors every year your
students get younger and they're looking
at you you are young Jesus yeah but I've
spent I spent four years in college
smoking pot and playing Sega Genesis
yeah libertarian there's always I can't
tell you just applaud everything or the
choice things what are you doing but but
the fact that people are at college and
coming to events like this and thinking
about these things is kind of beautiful
but let's move to a little bit of the
political stuff because we were going to
talk about free markets a little bit cuz
that's one of the things that I
definitely have changed and you know
most of my liberal beliefs about
live-and-let-live and especially on the
social things that you know gay marriage
of course and and you know you should be
able to drink whatever you want and
smoke whatever you want and the rest of
that that has not shifted but I
definitely have shifted as I as I've
come to this world and had these
discussions I definitely have shifted
right I would say economically because
I've realized that you should keep more
of what you earn so you can do what you
want with it whether it's spend it on
yourself or donate it to causes that you
believe in that the government basically
is especially the federal government is
just this monster that is constantly
wanting more and you know look how
pissed all the Trump people were when he
signed this omnibus package because he
came in and said we're gonna drive in
the swamp and what did he do he signed
the same old thing that funds Planned
Parenthood and a bunch of other things
that his base aids so the government
just the federal government especially
just keeps growing and growing and
growing I told you about the obscene
check that I wrote is living in
California that's that's at the state
level of course but I think it's
interesting that once you get the ideas
of freedom it's pretty obvious that it's
complete
linked to how your economics will change
as well it is I mean at the end of the
day you should have the power to make
decisions about your life right but if
you're if you're in California and
you're you you're poor and you're trying
to break through you know you have to
spend like 2,000 bucks to get a license
to shampoo here right I mean that's
insane you have to open it you have to
get a twenty thousand dollar government
approved program to open a nail salon it
because you know we're all gonna be
infected with that fungus and we're all
gonna you know it's just the government
needs to protect us otherwise what will
happen and then they also long yeah
right but what would you say to the
people that say that we'll wait a minute
if we left everything to be unregulated
that you know the nail salon would be
dumping the stuff in the river and oh
just all the sort of hysteria on this
that the government is the is the unit
that has to come in and make sure that
people aren't killing each other and
infecting each other in all Montrose
said it is hysteria that it's nothing
more than that and it's based on history
that is told from an historical
perspective that's not true history the
fact is the markets are brilliant and
beautiful at regulating themselves and
can I articulate for you the solution to
every one of these problems that exist
in the market no because the market
usually comes up with solutions that I
could never imagine but the fact is I
was listening I listened to NPR I admit
it Wow you know guilty as charged but LP
LP uh when I lived in California I'll
tell you where I live now in a minute
but when I lived in California was
writing those very large checks to the
government I still listen to NPR they
still run these stories about farming
and about food safety because food
safety is a big deal in California and
they used to interview the farmers and
without NPR really realizing what they
were doing the farmers would basically
say look the the people who come here
from the FDA yeah we can manage them
that's not really public it's those guys
from the supermarket's who come and
inspect our food they're really
difficult right it's really hard to get
by them right so who has an incentive to
make sure your food is safe McDonald's
does this supermarket does the
restaurant selling you the food us not
some leis
lazy whatever bureaucrat who's not gonna
lose this job if this e coli in the
salad because he's a government employee
and can't lose his job
but believe me if that was a private
contractor that supervised the salad and
it got he call a they are going to lose
their job the restaurant might lose
millions of customers and go out of
business there's real consequences in
the real world if something goes wrong
and people say I often say you know I
walk into the elevators anywhere in the
United States and you got a little
diploma on the wall and it says a
government supervisor supervise this
elevator and it will not fall you will
not die don't worry because we know
right we know all of us know that if not
for the government elevators would be
falling all across America totally but
we laugh right everybody laughs when I
say that but we really believe that I
mean really believe them right anybody
here who considers himself anything
short of a true free market uh believes
that because you believe in regulations
and all regulations are based on that
assumption right McDonald's the way if
if you let McDonald's completely
Unleashed like they would basically sell
you tainted meat because the best way to
make money is to kill your customers I
mean and the best way to run a nail
salon is to create fungus on the nails
or whatever it is that the danger is in
the nail so I mean that is bizarre and
that's not to live in the real world
with business people are the most
diligent people in the world to try to
make sure that their businesses are safe
that they're selling a good product and
those who are not get get go out of
business very quickly and getting
eliminated by the marketplace very
quickly and yeah the free market is
riskier is riskier they are risks in a
free market there is noise in a free
market its ups and downs in a free
market in a sense it's riskier than a
controlled market but the controlled
market the real risk of a controlled
market is it goes no way you can't live
you you get told what to do what to buy
what to eat what to drink how to live
and if your and this is the thing I
asked liberals right
if you don't think other people should
have a say in who you sleep with then
how can other people how said other
people have a say in what you sell how
is it that other people should have you
saying how you sell it or what what it
makes business different than any other
activity in life that you think should
be free what is it about money that that
suddenly other people get a say and how
you do your own business and and you
know it is it's it's the the the leftist
is fundamentally Marxist the
materialists so what they really care
about what any and I see this in debates
when I do about inequality what they
really care about is money
see I don't care that much about money
they really care about money so what
they want is the money and they want to
redistribute it and they want to take it
and they want to decide where it goes
they don't care about the spiritual
stuff they don't care about sex they
don't care about all that stuff that's
right you can do whatever you want with
that you can live your own life that way
the right cares about the spiritual
stuff right that they come from religion
where spiritual is important so that's
what they want irregularly that's what
they want to control that's what they
want to tell you how to live but they
don't really care about money money the
spirituals they don't really care about
money that much so that you could do
whatever the hell you want with right so
I say no I care about both I care about
the spiritual I give out the material
and I want to be able to make my own
decisions about both and it's none of
your business if I go bankrupt it's none
of your business if I if I commit I
don't know why we sue aside today yeah
why wants to say now you said watch oh
yeah if somebody come in to say it's
none of anybody's business what I do
with my life my life is mine and and
then people say well what about the pork
and I'm tempted right always to say to
somebody like that why do you care
because I really want to know why do you
care now I care about the poor at least
I care about some poor I don't care
about all the poor but I want to know
why is it that the first response I get
from any audiences what about the poor
what is it what what triggers that right
a your assuming the poor can't take care
of themselves
I don't I assume they're just as human
as anybody else they have the capacity
of work then capacity to produce
actually if you let them free they can
become anything they want to become
right there are no limitations and and
in free economies the poor
rise up and they do very well and indeed
the only place where Paul writes up is
in free condoms why do you care how many
people really can't take care of
themselves really can't find a job can
never do any of that stuff how many
people really can't and let you know
Kenna and they don't have any family
members to take care of them and they
don't have any friends to give them they
really destitute and nobody's there to
help them how many people like that are
they in the world yeah oh in America I
mean I mean II what's a percentage give
me a percentage yeah yeah so I know a
lot of people in 10% of the bought a
population they can they can do stuff I
can't do I you know I I was watching
this guy clean my windows
we were watching today and I write she
and she call go cleaning the window
sitting there cleaning the windows right
you don't need a high IQ for them but
you know what I couldn't do it you put
me anywhere close to that thing and how
wonderful that one for the hills despite
his apparent death wish today yeah
so I disagree with Jordan on that the
bottom two and Billy I was in the army
I was in the military and believe me the
Israeli military did not exclude the
bottom 10% of the distribution I was
with them in a tank and I know this is
this is real life right I mean the
dumbest VII men in these in the army I
met the dumbest people I've ever met in
my life I mean really really low IQ
people but were they decent people
absolutely could they function
absolutely could they function in a in a
combat absolutely
so I there the fact that the American
military Kenneth what's that they can
clean the windows oh yeah well we'll
pick it up at the UH no no but I'm
saying that they can clean the windows
they get plenty of jobs that plenty of
jobs for people who can't work at that
level and they do the jobs there plenty
of people with an IQ of under whatever
number you want
I know people down syndrome who bag
who go and work and I'm making a living
right
so the percentage of people who truly
cannot take care of themselves is under
well under 1% and then the question to
any audiences and then now we're talking
about that's under 1% now how many of
those don't have family and don't have
friends who could take care of them
that's a even smaller percentage and
then I ask every audience in the world
how many of you are willing to put a
little bit of money into a pot in order
to help that fraction of 1% of people
really canna take care of themselves
under any circumstances and everybody in
the room raises they had so what's what
do I need some gum and bureaucracy with
50,000 different programs employing
hundreds of thousands of people
institutionalizing people convincing
people that they can't take care of them
yeah well let's sit there for a second
because I think this is interesting
because even if the number let's say
your numbers are off let's just say it
was 5% right so I'm more than tripling
the the numbers that you're talking
about that if people were given back
more of their money because we're
funding all of these absurdly ridiculous
bureaucratic monstrosity Ziff people
were given back some of that money if
you actually care about poor people and
I do believe but you can ask the
question well why do you what I do
believe people want to do good but if
you had more money in your pocket and
you knew that the government was not
going to take care of those people then
I do think people would give more and I
also see this with you know something
like Planned Parenthood which in and of
itself I don't have a great issue with
but there is a certain amount of people
in the United States that are against
them providing abortions and I get it
it's a small percentage of what they do
but if the government was to not fund
Planned Parenthood which I wouldn't have
a problem with wouldn't all of these
celebrities that are constantly talking
about all the great things about Planned
Parenthood all of these people with
money if you're not changing the laws
wouldn't they put more money in and this
is where it this is where it does come
down to personal responsibility you can
make the world you want with your own
money and your own resources and skills
and volunteering and the rest of it as
opposed to just I think what it is
really I think the answer your question
is it's just laziness it's it's just
it's just going ah you know what let
them take
money do whatever they want they always
have money for bombs but we don't have
money for this well I always find people
say you know I would do it but those
yeah sold out today I wouldn't do it
right off
you know wouldn't do it and therefore we
have to force them because we know it's
the right thing to do it's the mall
thing to do but is it the right thing is
it a mall thing to do
I mean charity is fine but charity
doesn't define what morality is charity
doesn't define being wall and taking
care of the poor is not that it's not
that important it's not going to put any
of you it's not going to point to me
right be globally right because the fact
is I could write a big check right now
and send it to Africa and save a bunch
of kids lives I know that and I don't
because the fact is it's not that
important to me and I'm willing to say
that it's not and it's not to you you're
just most of you just won't say it right
because there's a kid dying every day in
in in Africa that you are not saving
right think of it that way this is a
what's his name Peter singers Peter
singers a famous philosopher and this is
the case he makes he makes you should
care because you should care about
everybody I don't care that much about
everybody I can't the closer you are to
me the more care about you
the further you offer me the less I care
about you because I care about myself
now again I don't want to live in a
society in in my society my particular
society my city whatever where people
way I know people are dying because
nobody's taking care of them so I'm
willing to give a little bit of charity
to do that a little bit up to a point
right but there's even another context
that I think people evade you we know
the direct correlation between wealth
creation and freedom I mean this is one
of the real truism in economics that you
you cannot dispute right it's it's in
Steven Pinker's latest book which you
should really read because the the
chapters about how good the world is are
just amazing and true right we know I
mean even Steven Pico comes from the
left will say this is because of markets
it's not because of government this is
because of market rate so we know the
correlation imagine the United States
with with all the human resources we
have in this country if we had a flea
market in this country
I can't imagine how rich we would be I
mean we think we're rich because we get
an iPhone 11
next this year right I always bring this
out right you always have to write
because I think this is the like my
setup my universe right but if you do
the math if you just add like 2 percent
to GDP growth over the last 20 years
what richer we would be we would be a
like an iPhone 100 no I mean it's it's
hard to imagine if the United States had
grown I can't remember the exact number
so I might be off a little bit but like
1% GDP less from the beginning of the
set of the 20th century till the end we
would be today poorer than Mexico 1
percent compounded makes a huge
difference so if we had a free market in
United States and we were growing at 5%
which i think is conservative in this
country 5% GD we would be so rich the
issue of the poor would never come up
because a we could write big checks
because we were so H but B they would be
like the amount of money we would pay to
have our windows cleaned would be high
because we could afford it so
everybody's saying of living would would
rise up as it always does people talk
about rising boats they do rise people
talk about trickle-down economics I'd
like to call it flood down economics
it's not trickle right everything every
every simple job that's out there is a
consequence of an entrepreneur who
created it every every every time that
somebody gets gets a raise it's because
capital is being invested and
productivity of Labor has gone up it's a
flood down it's that it's that it's the
the capitalists and the entrepreneurs
and the business leaders who create the
jobs equate the economy who drive the
economy so if you set them free the
amount of wealth we would have the
amount of prosperity we would be living
under is unimaginable to anybody living
today what's interesting about this I'd
like to shift this a little bit to
technology but I think it's it's a great
segue to that because if you listen to
all of the people right now mostly on
the left and the Bernie said of people
you know they're talking about this $15
minimum wage we also are living in a
time when robots are literally replacing
humans I mean I was at the airport in
Seattle not too long ago and at the I
forget if it's Burger King or McDonald's
instead
people they now have you know it's just
a big iPad and I've seen that in some
other places so the more that we demand
these businesses not have capacity over
what their own business decisions are
the more we're not going to be able to
give people decent jobs and also the
concept you know it's it's so
interesting because Bernie will talk
about well $15 an hour isn't a living
wage but you don't want that many people
to have those jobs that should be your
entry job to go get some other job and
also it's like I know this this is where
my my values have collided with my own
business is that right now we're trying
to expand the show and we're trying to
figure out what we're gonna do and I get
I get hundreds of people offering to
work for me for free and I don't want I
don't even want my interns for free I
mean I want to pay people but the idea
that I would have to pay someone X
amount now I want to pay my guys more
than $15 an hour and we're trying to
figure out all sorts of things and we by
the way we pay a hundred percent of my
employees health insurance if you're
looking for another job but I'm not
moving back together
I want to talk a little bit about
California too
but but the idea that the government can
manage these things that the I mean
Bernie has never created a job he's
never created anything III think he has
three or four houses he doesn't let poor
people live in those houses you know
he's made a lot of money off of being a
government being a senator for thirty
years who's pretty much done nothing and
if you really include getting across the
aisle he's really done nothing but it
all sounds good that was the point that
I'm trying except ultimately it just
what you said about I don't care about
poor people it sounds it even to me
sitting here doesn't sound good I know
then Bernie comes in and goes $15
everyone's going to college bah-bah-bah
and it all kind of makes everyone feel
good yeah see I say that but I care
about the poor much more than Bernie
does because I want to create a system
in which the poor are not poor anymore
nobody nobody should be poor if we had a
true free market nobody would be poor
right
and the fact is and again look at
Stephen Pincus book the fact is that
nobody in America today is poor if what
poverty means what poor people
middle-class was a hundred years ago or
what the rich was a hundred years ago
rich people hundred years ago lived
worse off than poor people do today but
we have super computers in our pockets
even poor people have super computers in
their pockets that's stunning but you
said something kind of funny before
right nobody laughed because robots are
taking people's jobs literally right now
that's funny because robots have been
taking people's jobs for 200 years
right the first sewing machines took
people's jobs every single piece of
technology that is being introduced over
the last 200 years has taken people's
jobs and what were the consequences
fewer or more jobs not just a little bit
more jobs a lot more jobs we have a
population today of 8 billion people on
the planet let's assume that about 2
billion of them actually working and in
in I mean not subsistence farming
actually working and they're grown up
two billion people working in jobs what
we call jobs right we're talking about
200 years ago the population of the
world was less than half a billion
almost all of them were subsistence
farmers there were no jobs ever since
we've introduced technology all that has
happened all that has happened is we've
created more and more and more and more
and more jobs we've never had a period
over the last 200 years where we got
fewer jobs there's always more because
the population just exploded over the
last over the last 200 years and yet
everybody has a job and indeed the free
of the economy is the more jobs there
are like the United States in the 19th
century was absorbing massive quantities
of immigrants because the capitalism
technology industrialization robots
create more jobs than they destroy
always always so I don't I don't get
what the what people are worried about
about robots now ask me what the jobs of
the future
I don't know I mean I know a few that I
would like like a personal masseuse that
travels with you everywhere I mean
you're starting to appreciate this
the final travel schedule something like
that yeah you know maybe you were my
personal masseuse yeah let's talk about
that later he charges a lot expensive so
he's not regulated by the government
it's a whole freakin thing no license
right yeah no license you're looking at
an unlicensed on the face up here people
I've no idea we'll get back to that in a
moment all right so that's you know
we've already done more than an hour
here and we haven't really fly by and I
do want to get to QA because I always
find that's actually where where we can
kind of learn the most but I quickly
want to just bring this back to
technology in California because you
escaped California you couldn't take it
anymore I was at Berkeley two weeks ago
I didn't event with turning-point and we
we had dinner out in San Francisco that
night and literally driving to Berkeley
from San Francisco there are tent cities
all over the place I mean this is this
is the progressive utopia right I mean
the San Francisco this is the lefty
place that they want to model the rest
of the country after there were tent
cities everywhere I saw I kid you not I
saw a guy shooting up in an alley while
we were taking a turn when we went to
dinner and we were on a nice Street we
went to a steak house our car was parked
outside the car was broken into and they
stole my bag so there's some junky
running around San Francisco in my
underwear telling my jokes because my
comedy my comedy notebook was in there
if I could picture some guy 210
something going on and on about the
regressive left already
you bet you now have material for a
whole show no I know I'm just done there
that he's opening for me now but but
this was the progressive utopia this
place oh so then so then I take a
picture get this I take a picture of the
broken glass in the window of the car
and I get literally hundreds of people
telling me don't you know there is an
epidemic in this city about people just
punching and windows and stealing [ __ ]
and then on top of that people started
telling me this is absolute
be true there is an app for people in
San Francisco to download so that you
can find out where human feces is on the
street so that you can avoid those
streets when you're walking because a
dog once they just forget the dog no the
dog poop we're good but literally for
human poop and you have to download an
app to do that this is in the
progressive utopia where now drugs have
run rampant I mean Berkeley Berkeley
looks like a circus it really does look
like like a carny show out there always
has been looked at well Berkeley was the
home Berkeley won at one time was the
home of freedom I mean it was the home
of free snow but with the people who
advocated for free speech in Berkeley
didn't weren't advocating for freedom
they were advocating for a particular
type of oppression because they were
they were they were the leftist of today
they were the professors who turned the
group of students who today are the nuts
into what they are so I don't I don't
have a romantic vision of the free
speech movement of the 1960s I mean I
knew and rode extensively about that
what was going on in campuses in the 60s
and it was bad it was not true freedom
they didn't understand what the concept
of freedom really was it was again a
rejection of reason a rejection of
individualism rejection of capitalism
all in the name of doing whatever we
feel like doing right feel like doing it
before we should be able to feel like
saying whatever it wasn't it was not a
proper defense of free speech and that's
why it lost but look it's not this is
the thing nobody learns from experience
there's a statement for you nobody
learns from experience right if people I
see learned from what works and what
doesn't work then we will be living in
Las defeat capitalist heaven but they
don't right
I mean Berkeley's nothing as competitive
Venezuela Venezuela people are starving
to death little babies don't get food
they starve people have eaten all their
pets they broken into the zoos they've
eaten all the animals in the zoos and
they just isn't any more food and people
are literally dying right millions of
people have not exited Venezuela and
going to Colombia right not exactly a
place you want to escape to you know
define prosperity but it's so much
richer than Venezuela right and yet
this is socialism this is always the
consequence of socialism and yet you've
got all these young people who want to
be socialists and and they said no
that's isn't the real socialism ok so
whatever show isms never been tried
that's the one that they'll say but
every person who's ever said they were
trying socialist created a hell hole
right so take take on the one hand you
say that about San Francisco but also
what you notice in San Francisco it's
the high-rises going up I mean it's on I
you know I lived in San Jose close to
San Francisco 20 years ago and it's
unidentifiable it's a city's completely
changed the whole saw South of Market
phenomena skyscrapers the construction
even here in Chicago construction every
way so in the one hand you've got this
booming and on the other hand you've got
massive quantities of homeless people
because homeless people know that
nothing will happen to them they could
poop anywhere in San Francisco and
there's an app that nobody cares you
know in La La's another example with
their homeless people everywhere and why
and people always wondered why they
homeless people and and because the City
of LA has guaranteed that they will
build housing for all the homeless
people so they keep building housing and
putting the homeless people in and yet
they always are more homeless people and
they don't understand whether these
homeless people come from well I don't
know about you guys but when somebody's
offering free stuff like free housing
I'm not gonna stay homeless and Chicago
where it's cold I'm gonna go somewhere
where it's warm and they promised free
housing so the more they build homes for
homeless people don't want less people
there will be that's basic incentives
this is not hard
sophisticated economics this is how the
world works
right so you know California is this
country the state of complete you know
dramatic extremes you know I live lived
in each county which is like the most
pleasant place to live on the planet
it's so beautiful big streets
everybody's basically rich and life is
wonderful but you go out to the Central
Valley or you go to Skid Row in LA or
you see people as poor as anywhere in
the United States and it's that's what
you haven't in
californian fewer and fewer people in
the middle you have wealth and you have
poverty and and people in the middle
somehow getting by because the real
estate keeps getting more expensive and
nobody can afford to live in San
Francisco anymore
and you know what people blame the fact
there was just an amazing story in the
Mercury News which is the local
newspaper in the Bay Area who do they
blame for the high cost of living in San
Francisco who's to blame what Sam from
who's to blame technology companies
because they creating too many jobs
they're creating too many jobs right so
they're pricing out so so too many
people are coming so it's it's their
fault right and of course the last piece
Phil there blame is local government now
it turns out that as an economist and
you go there they're only people to
blame a local government because now
building they're not giving permits
they're not building high then up but
you know so they say there's not enough
room to go link build high instead of
just office buildings build condos they
don't build condos in San Francisco but
why why don't they build condos in San
Francisco because the people who live in
the nice houses don't own doats not in
my backyard not in my backyard so
nobody's they don't build high-rises
even you know expensive high-rises they
just don't want Bayview's block they
don't want whatever right so no but the
fault is we're creating too many jobs
it's those greedy capitalists creating
too many jobs and creating too much
wealth and creating the iPhone whatever
you know that's the problem it's it's
it's mind-boggling and this this is not
hard stuff
so yeah you should be able to look at
San Francisco and say we don't want that
you should be able to look at Venice or
let's say we don't want that you should
go be able to go to Hong Kong and say
whoa
what did they do right or go to the
United States and look at the 19th
century look at what we started what we
ended up and go whoa I want to be like
that so this is goes back to the mall a
point I made earlier
let's go study what works and what
doesn't that's true in economics that's
true in politics it's true in life I'm a
scientist I want to be a scientist I
want to go on in nature and figure out
what works and what doesn't work and I
want to do what works on I wanna vote oh
it doesn't work not work in a moment but
work over over a lifetime right
and where works is capitalist and what
works at flea markets was works is you
know a certain approach to your own
individual life and what doesn't work is
socialism and and and focusing on you
know guilt and taking care of others and
and and all of that if you live a good
life for yourself and if everybody had
that attitude or most people had that
attitude Wow
you know whenever to be tried it works
amazing all we have to do is is do it
right just just do it that's an achy
things yeah just do it there you go
nice and just a runny right now and
really if you want how bananas have
gotten in in San Francisco in Silicon
Valley
Peter Thiel he's taking his companies
and leaving and he's moving to the
freedom-loving Los Angeles unbelievable
think about that really joyful lack he
left a slightly less wacky but in his
estimation that that is how crazy that
thing is god I want to mention one other
thing that we'll get to the queues I
moved just so we were clear enough to
Puerto Rico yeah yes I live in Puerto
Rico now he doesn't just talk about not
yet he's living it yeah I'm living it
cuz my taxes in Puerto Rico are
somewhere around 4% all in federal state
everything yeah yeah and putting a lot
of political party in Puerto Rico so if
you guys move yeah you know we're gonna
take the place over alright maybe maybe
I'll be the mayor of San Juan or
something you know final thought you
mentioned Orange County and if you want
to talk about a really oppressive state
government I the first time I went to
Orange County I went to a journey
concert and I got busted for smoking
weed at a journey concert which I
thought you had to have into a jury so
that is what is wrong the government all
right well this been an absolute
pleasure let me talk to the camera for a
second because I do believe in
capitalism and all of the good
freedom-loving stuff that you're on and
I have talked about here and most likely
this video has been demonetized by
YouTube already we are on patreon so
this live stream right now is we're
gonna air the QA on that but if you're
watching this on tape delay as it were
what year did I come up with that phrase
from TV the Q&A that we're about to do
is going to be a patreon exclusive
although it'll all be air
live right now